the way I took aola in the very
beginning started a different way
slightly U every time we meet with a
client by definition we're going to be
exposed to tremendous amount of critical
human intelligence client needs
competitors pricing Etc everyone that I
share the stuff with him or with her to
say yeah absolutely and then ask
yourself a question how much of that is
actually being captured and they're all
going to scratch their head and say very
little and you know crm's been around
the world since 1999 amazing commercial
success operationally
M I haven't found a single guy to say oh
my God M I'm so excited going to log to
salesport so HP or anybody else you do
it because you have to not because you
want to you treat it as a chore
unfortunately and therefore it's
reflected in the quality quantity
[Music]
time Amir harati welcome to 20 minute
leaders I'm so excited to have you here
we're gonna have so much fun over these
next 20 minutes talking about your own
Incredible Journey and having been and a
really big part of of some of the most
impressive and I guess proud companies
in the Israeli ecosystem that that I
grew up H you know learning about and
and thinking through what it must be
like to be part of them and today you're
also the CEO Bola which has made a lot
of noise especially recently H with your
work around language and speech and and
how they translate no pun intended to
organizations and enterpris so a lot for
us to uncover am tell me a little bit
about yourself because you mentioned
something interesting to me that you
don't see yourself as a serial
entrepreneur but rather something else
yes so thank you again M for having me
it's a pleasure to be here and having
fun it's having fun in everything we do
it's the name of the game so if we fail
to do so we're in the wrong business
absolutely so yeah actually you know um
some people like to call me Ser
entrepreneur uh I don't think that is a
great compliment um I rather be called
as a serial Problem Solver because one
of the things I constantly do and the
more I do the hungrier I get and uh I
can assure you I'm going to make less
mistakes I'm going to make some new
mistakes but you know you know how to do
things better and more efficient but the
key there is to find some fundamental
problem that touching a lot of people's
life that if you can solve or do it
better or smarter it's really going to
make an impact in a way you can quantify
very very quickly I always joke that the
three letters that I love the most in
the English language is r o n i and if
you can quantify it and demonstrate it
and again it's a Cheesy way to do it but
the key there is all about it's not
about the technology no disrespect to
the great technology it's about the
value you generate as long as you can
quantify and demonstrate
it absolutely that's give me in you know
three you know big problems that you're
really excited about So when you say
that you know really put in this the
problem at the center that's challenging
building a great team around it what are
some examples of these types of problems
that get you really
excited so the kid there you know I've
been involved in cyber I've been
involved in Big Data I've been involved
in many different areas I've been
fortunate enough to be uh the global
head of sales for aobi that we
eventually sold to synel and a
significant exit back in
2012 I've been lucky enough to be
associated with onavo that eventually
was sold to Facebook I was involved with
mintigo that was eventually sold to
anaplan uh I was the co of adalon that
was sold to Microsoft um and so I've
been lucky enough to be around great
people solving amazing problems and
demonstrating value for investors and
and uh buyers and eventually I got deep
into the AI business long before a and I
became the most used and abused letters
in English language at present time and
the way I've done it initially was an
amazing journey because we were the AI
platform of choice of one of the largest
management consulting companies in the
world so over there in six years period
in a six years time span I had a chance
to be part of a triple digit engagements
with the Fortune 500
companies so you can imagine that one of
every five uh seev executive had a
chance with the management consulting
company to be part of and I learned a
lot of things what to do and a lot of
things to do differently and the first
thing I
learned while I'm a disruptor and I
enjoy very much to disrupt it took me
maybe too long to realize that most
people in the world don't like to be
disrupted and that's when you eat a
little you know you need to eat a
littleit of a humble pie you know my
mother always told me you have two ears
and one mouth try to keep that
proportion okay listen more and I'm
still working on that but the key there
I'll give you an example uh last week I
was in Vegas in one of the largest
hotels 7100 worlds and I was meeting
with a head of uh
maintenance and that head of Maintenance
uh came with a Furniture okay he started
with this organization when it was a
hole in the ground and and I saw him
immediately when it they presented me
talking about Ai and I can see the fear
in his and the rejection in his
eyes and I started Jim how long you been
here and say since 1997 said okay one
thing for sure I'm never going to learn
what you already forgot about your
business so I'm not here to tell you
what you doing wrong I'm here to help
you do what you do better and smarter
and safer and I can this is a part of
the learning that really got me to
understand that when I'm trying to solve
problem is not to disrupt is to augment
to enhance in the most nonthreatening
way because at the end of the day
success breeds success and if you can
show those people that the technology is
there not for technology sick but in
order to help them to do things better
that's really led me to what I'm doing
over here incredible okay so walk me
through aola and and how is Zola's space
and Technology improving and empowering
so actually aola uh the way I took aola
in the very beginning started in a
different way slightly U every time we
meet with a client by definition we're
going to be exposed to tremendous amount
of critical human intelligence client
needs competitors pricing Etc everyone
that I shared the stuff with him or with
her say yeah absolutely and then ask
yourself a question how much of that is
actually being captured and they're all
going to scratch their head and say very
little and you know crm's been around
the world since 1999 amazing Commercial
Success
operationally M I haven't found a single
guy to say oh my God M I'm so excited
going to log salesport so abort anybody
else you do it because you have to not
because you want to you treat it as a
chore unfortunately and therefore it's
reflected in the quality quantity timing
and I say what if just finish a meeting
with Mel and I learned that he SPS his
time half and half where he's serving in
military he just got an amazing term shs
behind him etc etc while I'm walking to
the elevator in in natural language I
can tell aola what I just learn and Iola
will grab it and automatically integrate
it to the CR of choice in the name aola
AI Ola the most important letter is not
a o i it's actually the O and it's not
an O It's a fat intelligence Loop of
collecting integrating processing
delivering post meeting collection pre-
meeting preparation and with that in
mind I got incredible investors that put
some good money as a seed round and
within several months had $34 million of
ARR with Fortune 50 Fortune 100 Fortune
500 00
amazing and then February 2422 the war
in Europe
started and even before the craziness in
our neighborhood I realized that we
arguably facing one of the biggest
perfect storm in modern history the
combination of geopolitical and
macroeconomic elements are forcing a
situation when people are going to make
a clear separation between what
perceived to be nice to have versus must
have whatever is nice to have forget
about it I don't have time for cosmetic
surgery I have to stay alive
and then you know you know in Psychology
there's the maslo Pyramid of nits so I
created mayola for mola's perspective
doesn't matter what's going on in the
world which are the verticles which are
immune so it doesn't matter what's going
in the world we have to eat food
industry it doesn't the Pharma industry
supply chain energy semiconductor it's
easy to identify five or six verticals
and as much as I'm very proud of what we
have done in a post meeting collection
preting preparation
thought we may be perceived rightly or
wrongly but perception is reality if you
like it or not as nice to have and
before it's going to hit the f I decided
on my own to call it a pivot call it
whatever you want but to take our
technology and apply it to the following
blueprint must of verticals critical
processes where you can demonstrate
quantifiable r y at scale that's it so I
pick up the phone and I call a fortune
60 company that I know very well from my
management consulting days and I say
it's a fortune 60 company food
manufacturer when you start your day you
just flip a button and start production
of course not I have to complete this
highly regulatory preop inspection fast
forward is a 20 Pages process manually
done every morning at 4:30 in the
morning that keeps production night at
two hours and I say whoa what if we're
going to turn the entire process to
speech based handsfree paperless they're
going to walk and talk and the forms are
going to be filled it's going to be way
more efficient smarter safer
collaborative decided to do a pilot
decided to use ASR automatic speech
recognition which is not new off the
shelf took the recording from Australia
that's where we piloted it and I was
super disappointed to find out that
maximum accuracy Gap was
52% so first I thought maybe it's the
oie accent it didn't help but that was
not the reason second acoustic
environment solvable turns out that more
than 50% of the language used was not
English was jargon of the specific
industry specific location and In
fairness there's no technology of the
shelf that can deal with that so I
realize there's a huge problem an even
bigger
opportunity so we realize that jargon is
a key blocker number one and second is
the fact that I don't want to talk about
football or basketball or the playoffs
or anything else I want to be
automatically to pull out the keywords
which are relevant Now speech by
definition is the most efficient and
natural means of communication everybody
agrees and eventually eventually
voice first will be the human machine
interface but it's not there because the
quality the accuracy right now it's sub
60% so I came with that concept was able
to raise a $25 million a around in
January 23 which is significant
achievement by itself but very good
Investments investors hemton Lane which
is a fund of fund of funds uh managing
93 billion dollar made a huge exception
to be to lead ours and um we had a
massive breakthrough in technology in
January wrote several patents in IP and
took nine months to develop the product
the product was launched in September 23
you know what happened in October but
that's not an excuse and what we have
done is we took the Jon that we created
an incredible and you saw the Venture
bit article last week and the keyword
spotting but more than that we combine
it to a very unique way to do that
because at the end of the day what we're
doing right now you know with L
Ms you're boiling the ocean in brute
force and then you're trying to go to
something very narrow and you know in
Hebrew we do everything from the wrong
direction we speak from the wrong
direction we read from the wrong
direction one day I'm look at my coffee
and I say why do I need to boil the
ocean in order to make coffee so I
pulled Professor keshet my uh Chief
scientist who used to be the head of uh
uh Speech research at Alexa at
Amazon and I called Yosi and I say Yosi
how much data do you need in order to
create the language oh I need no no no
for a specific form so here is a great
example for one of the largest TI
manufacturer in the world in Korea when
I demonstrated to him our ability to do
it in 95% accuracy versus the 58% that
he saw until now he was blown away but
then he asked me how much data do you
need in order to generate the model I
said actually all I need is one form in
Korean that's
it and actually then we taken gen and we
generated millions of synthetic samples
and we build a platform that called
jonic which is trademarked that actually
I can now tailor a specific micro
language model for a specific form of
work process in a language I don't
understand in the domain I know nothing
about with accuracy north of 95% in few
hours and I don't care you know one of
the largest uh uh shipping companies
that deliver packages to your home came
to me and say oh we have more than
100,000 vehicles and every vehicle every
morning has to go to a six they call it
it's a very ambitious name 60 seconds
quick look audit it's a 40 Point
checklist and ask them two simple
questions is one where's the data going
to Nowhere second I know it sounds
stupid but how long does it take it to
do the so-called 60cs quick look audit
and they left and say 15 to 20 minutes
and now they're doing the entire process
by speech in 52 seconds or less so we
saving more than 50 minutes per Vehicles
times 100,000 per day and in addition
now the data is streaming for 100,000
vehicles and now you know how the tires
behave in Miami versus how they behave
in Toronto Canada and then came the
other big career company and say oh by
the way we more interested in NPS and
customer satisfaction and if today
you're getting a package which was
damaged you got your term and it
was raining in Palo Alto and the paper
was damaged and you telling the CER what
just happened I say I apologize please
go online and follow report which is a
black hole he asked me a question can
you open up a ticket by speech said sure
can you do it in Mandarin because we
want to demo it in in Singapore I think
so can you integrate to Pega no
disrespect I had no idea what Pega is
and then I checked it's a very
respectable company with backend system
for
crms 10 days later the entire process in
Mandarin for that specific career done
by speech fully integrated to Pega and
then came a one so in a very short
period of time what we have done we
built some bleeding edge technology when
taking care and addressing the es of
speech which is the most natural means
of communication and eventually every
human machine
interface in one end we have the
bleeding edge technology on other end
any Android or iOS device so onboarding
is can be minutes or hours I play nice
so I can integrate to whatever you have
in place and at the end I'm stupid as I
gets I know nothing but any vertical but
I have the same platform used right now
by French Canadian supermarket chain in
Montreal they're doing the temp
mandatory temperature check of the meat
inside refrigerator by speech in French
Canadian that's feature alone saves them
more than 110,000 hours a year that
little feature and I'm doing that right
now for a cruise ship they doing the
safety checklist for the ship before
they leave the port by speech and I'm
and I'm doing out to Big farmer to do it
for Quality so I'm like a kid in a toy
store going back to your question in the
beginning took a massive problem find a
clever way to address it to make it real
simple real flat and now it's down to
execution so then it sounds like you've
this big problem that you're talking
about is so fundamental that above it
you can then identify a bunch of really
cool Nifty problems that take hundred of
thousand hours for an organization and
and then be able to leverage that clever
that clever technique which is which it
doesn't sound simple at all I mean
effectively you're saying youve you you
the technology you've built is able to
fine tune based on very small amount of
data because you're able to generate
a a large a good enough data set to
reach high enough accuracy for a good
user experience that's not trival alone
absolutely and if you know I did this
service and I you know I I downplayed
the level of complexity behind the scene
but you're absolutely right but the
beauty of it put it on top of it m
everything you say is absolutely right
in a non-threatening way because at the
end of the day it's change management
you're dealing with people and I love
the fact you know one of the largest VCS
in Silicon Valley came to me and say me
you know we invested heavily in AI
companies in the last five years but
most if not all were Tech startups that
were selling to Tech
startups and you're actually going after
those big elephants big
Enterprises wow Amir you're found a blue
ocean I said first thank you for the
compliment one I don't think I deserve
it uh second I don't think it's a blue
ocean because a blue ocean it's
something somewhere that all of us are
running to and here those are type of
industries that nobody was even looking
at it's huge but it's not blue ocean
it's a yellow Des yellow desert that
desperately looking for the drip
irrigation to turn yellow to green and
as soon as I finish that conversation I
printed t-shirt for the entire company
that says on the back ever green and
yellow desert uh but I love the the the
junction where the most advanced
technology is meeting traditional
companies and you can imagine that in
every boardroom right now there's a
question is what are you guys doing with
AI and the hype and again and rightly
saw the hype that took place in the last
18 24 months by gen it's incredible but
the hype is gone and now everybody's
looking for practical gen how this is
going to meet my bottom line and if I'm
saving 110,000 hours for a supermarket
chain with the margins of 4% because
that's a margin in the supermarket
business this is going directly to the
ABA this can be quantifiable you know I
met many cyber security company and I
work in some and ask investors how do
you quantify Roi for Sager so fear
Factor insurance or whatever you want to
call it but I love the direct line and
you know in many situations I'm sitting
with potential clients and I show the
the technology I get very excited but at
the same time is this is amazing how
much it cost and then I smile and I say
I don't care of course I care but I'm
not chasing price I'm chasing value and
it's not me versus you it's you and me
together chasing value and there's no
value to be generated I don't want your
money I don't want to waste my time but
if there's value to be generated let's
do it right and that's a journey so when
I started with this uh uh courier
company we start with a single use case
now we identify 31 use cases from
automation to Aviation to assorting
facilities and it's endless you know I'm
talking right now to uh uh even to those
uh big hotels in Vegas and you're
talking from 7,000 rooms when you have
the housekeeping defects and you have
the modern day Tower of Babylon so many
languages so many and they don't really
feel any forms and now they can do the
checklist at the end of every room and
do speak it in fluent Armenian or idish
uh whatever language of choice and the
form will be filled in line and then it
turns out that they have you know they
have to inspect the water coolers and
the chillers and the hit heat pumps and
every shift and you can do it by speech
and it's going to save them more than
half of the time but now the data is
going to be captured so you can now
predictive maintenance and do the
procurement based on it and then we
found out that every slot machine need
to be inspected multiple times a day and
every time I go to meet with a client
it's unbelievable like I was meeting
with a major client the other day and
they say look at each other and say
warranties so what do you mean warranty
say well we have a fleet of hundreds of
thousand vehicles and let's assume that
this vehicle right now is broken and we
need to replace the alternator we're
going to do it in the field but the
technician is never going to take the
time to go back to the office and log
into information to activate the
warranties we're losing tens of millions
of dollars and unactivated warranties a
year just because the information is not
being submitted now but if I'm doing now
I'm doing a speech with AA and take a
picture and I put in numbers I'm
activating the warranty from the field
while I'm doing it so the direct and so
this I love that Journey M because yes
I'm solving a big problem that every day
getting even bigger in Direction I could
never even
imagine I had the other day I had a very
interesting conversation we started
talking to
Oracle and then I got a a email telling
me Larry is very eager to talk to
you and uh I was actually sitting in a
in a bomb shelter in the north U and
Larry Alis jump on a
call and I'm jumping and amazing by the
way what a what a privilege and after
talking for about 30 minutes I'm here
this is amazing he's very passionate
about Healthcare I say Amir I would love
to take it to healthcare and I say you
know Larry that's the only place I may
disrespect respectfully disagree with
you because I'm looking for places where
I can make the biggest impact at the
shortest period of time with me minimum
obstacle possible and arguably it's not
Healthcare but yet he wanted us to show
something so we took a process that
Oracle Field Services is doing for uh
home healthare and we took the entire
process where the nurse come to the
patient house and checks the vitals and
checks out in Mobile the person is and
replace oxygen and everything by speech
and everything is captured with 100%
accuracy in real time and integrated so
it's it's an incredible journey that
just started I'm very proud of the
breakthrough we have done with
technology but I'm even prouder how we
took the technology breakthroughs and
Implement in a way that saves money and
helps organization to stay relevant and
help organization to do more with less
and help organization to maintain you
know I'm not here to upend
society I'm here to contribute I'm here
to complement I'm here to enhance and
augment I'm here what a journey thank
you so much for spending this time with
me I'm I'm completely inspired by what
you're doing and
and more than the than the outcome of
what you're doing the the motivation
behind it and the the the why and which
obviously shows with the I think it's
such a privilege being able to take this
breath of experience that you've had H
and bringing it now to a world in which
you have this this cutting is technology
that is you're now able to implement it
and you instead of fearing this blue
ocean you're actually looking at it as a
yellow desert but but uh but uh creating
the greenery around it and so um really
really proud of of this conversation and
an incredible work that you've done Amor
so thank you so much for for T spending
this time with me and best of luck with
all I'll keep you from the site thank
you for having me it's been a pleasure
thank you so much